hello everyone welcome
back to the collider channel we have
another exclusive interview i am
so excited to welcome stanley tucci to
the channel and especially
to talk about supernova i'm sure you're
hearing this a lot right now but uh
this is something else and you and colin
are both incredible in it
oh thank you thank you yes i seem to
like it i'm
i'm glad so to start off here
this is a beautiful movie but i can't
imagine it was very easy living in a
story like that for an extended period
of time
and i know there might be a whole bunch
of answers to this question
but what would you say it was about the
script that made you say
i've got to make this commitment i've
got to be a part of telling the story
it was so beautiful it was so
beautifully written
it it was restrained it was poetic
it was um
um it was truthful
um it was just gorgeous
and you don't come along you know
scripts like that don't come along very
often
uh and then i watched harry's first
film harry mcqueen the director and
watched his first film
which i thought was equally as beautiful
and poignant
in a different way but he and also the
fact that he had made that movie
in 11 days i think for 10 000 pounds
and as an independent filmmaker i know
how hard that is to do
and i thought it was gorgeous and then i
met with him and he was
equally as wonderful as wonderful as his
films so
it was a pretty easy i was so flattered
that he asked me to do it and then i
thought that you know
colin would be right and i mentioned
that to harry
after of course i gave calling the
script and um
then it all worked out i have so many
follow-ups where to begin
maybe first the idea of this movie
having
restraints but specifically when it
comes to the history of the
characters because i'm always really
fascinated when a script manages to
convey that a character exists beyond
the immediate story that you're
experiencing
without actually giving you that
information so
for you trying to bring that to screen
are you able to do anything on set to
make sure that's coming across or is
that mostly just
in the script it's it's in the script
but things are always
altered every day when you're when
you're filming
when you're making a film first you do a
little bit you talk through the script
um you know in rehearsals we just had
like a day or so of
rehearsal a little bit just to run
through scenes and play around with
stuff and
and then we would talk and say like well
maybe this scene we don't need
this line or maybe this maybe we don't
need that maybe this could you know
uh but basically we stayed within if we
did
anything we stripped away things from
from an
already sort of a sparsely written
script
again because harry had done so much
research
and written it so truthfully
you didn't need to say a lot but what
you did say
was uh really meant really meant
something i find that i usually get a
little obsessive with character
backstory when
the characters really strike a chord so
even though i want more
i feel like it's because you guys are
successful in what you just gave me
yeah good good i'm glad yeah because
there was no i mean we don't
there was no back i mean the back story
was you know they've been together for
20 years
you know and he does this he does this
they love each other
that's it you don't need the specifics
to still feel the weight i don't know
sometimes you can get bogged down in
that and then the writer can get bogged
down
or the actor can get bogged down and
it doesn't do anybody any good
just because i'm curious now is there
any example of a
past project where i don't know in order
to not
get bogged down by that you had to strip
something
away from the character that was in the
script that you were meant to have said
that
served the character better to have not
said at all
oh absolutely every script i'm not
kidding
i mean literally every movie i do
i take away people always say well act
people always think or maybe there are
some actors like this they want
people to want more lines most actors
don't they want less lines they want
fewer lines
because well when you get to be my age
they're harder to remember
but also you
the real reason is that you you know
what you can do
without saying a word and i think as you
get older and
you do it more you know that maybe you
have to say
less and less i'm not saying every film
should be that way
some characters are obviously it's
warranted that they're more
more verbose than others but generally
speaking
most dialogue is overwritten and
it's it's unfortunately a lot of times
falls to the actor
to sort of go let's take that away that
way that way that way that way that way
that way and then once the
often the director hears it they go oh
yeah we
don't need that so now going back to
the research for this because i know
that harry really did his work
in that respect but for you in
particular what kind of research
did you do into young onset dementia and
maybe also the particular type that
tusker is facing and is there any
specific thing you learned that maybe
functioned as an anchor of sorts while
you were playing the role
yeah um i harry was
harry just gave us all of his research
uh
articles uh documentaries all that sort
of stuff
and you just kind of immerse yourself in
it
particularly for me particularly helpful
for me were the documentaries
um louis thoreau had made a couple of
shows episodes on it um
there's that glenn campbell documentary
um there are a number of things we
talked to a doctor who showed us footage
of patients and
um there are a lot there's a lot of
stuff that stuff was
invaluable to me and i think one of the
things that was really interesting
it's very hard to watch because it's
hard it's heartbreaking
so i could only watch it for little bits
at a time and then you just
you know it's so moving and it's
and anxiety uh causing um
but one of the things that was really
interesting to me was
the
you know people would disappear for a
moment and then suddenly they'd come
back but of course they had no idea that
they disappeared
so that is frightening
and but fast and it and it happened to
almost all of them in the same way but
also
when they were asked to do something
um and this this particular kind of
uh early onset is is connected to the
to the visual and when they were asked
to do something like grab
a cup out of someone's hand or write
a number or something like that they
would go to do it and they
wouldn't be able to do it and the first
thing they would do
is laugh after after it
they'd go oh yeah
and then and you see that in the in the
glen campbell documentary too
and the laughter what is that laughter
the laughter is
how absurd that i couldn't do it i'm
also deflecting
my pain or anxiety about it
uh and you know there's there's so much
in that laugh
um so to me that was
that was that was that that was a kind
of anchor for me
so now going back to working with harry
but actually
maybe start with a broader directing
question for you because
we know that what you direct and you act
so when you first started directing is
there any project that you signed on for
as an actor where you found that
directing brain
kicking in more so than ever in terms of
determining whether or not you wanted to
sign on for that project
oh yeah absolutely yeah i don't i can't
say
which one particular but i know that
that that that happens
and there are certain projects
yeah yeah and there are so there are
certain projects that you're asked to do
and you think oh god i wish i were
directing this you know like
and then you think and then sometimes
you meet the director and you think
oh boy i really wish i were directing
this you know because this person
doesn't know what they're doing
or or
my god i never could have directed this
this person is amazing um
there was one movie a hollywood movie
that i was asked to do
and it and i said i i just don't
think that i know how to do that and
and i won't tell you what it was i was
asked by the by the star of the movie
to do it and then the movie ended up
being
very successful and somebody said to me
see it was so successful why didn't you
direct it it was so good why didn't you
direct it i said
it was so good and successful because i
didn't direct it
that's why if i if i
i mean it's just like it it doesn't make
any sense that someone would say that
but you know to me you you have to
it's it's good to have the eye of a
director when you're acting because it
challenges
the director you're able to ask all the
right questions
you just have to make sure that you're
not annoying
because it's not your movie so now kind
of flipping that around to harry a
little because he also has experience
acting in addition to directing so can
you see that uh
giving his actor his style when
directing his actors a unique touch that
he has the experience in both
departments
oh absolutely yes absolutely the thing
about harry
is that he's a gentleman
and a gentle man um and
he is extremely intelligent
and you see very well that he'll he'll
give you
and he gives you very little direction
really uh
but you know that just from his script
that he knows about acting and then you
know when he's on
set because he doesn't give you a lot of
direction that he knows about acting
it's now looping colin into this because
i know
you had already mentioned i believe that
you played a part in bringing him
aboard on this project so what was it
when
this opportunity came up that made you
think he is perfect
to start opposite me in this movie was
it your past collaborations uh some of
his other work your friendship you name
it
everything everything you just said uh i
love him we've been friends for
20 years um he's an incredibly
[Music]
good person and a great friend he's a
great
father he's and he's just one of the
best actors
ever um and we have the best time
together
we don't seem to get bored of each other
i don't which doesn't really make any
sense
because we're not very interesting and
he
he's just great and i read it and i
thought oh my god colin has to do this
and um and then of course i started like
i slipped it to colin without
telling harry which was naughty and
um uh but then harry was like oh wow do
you think he'd do it i go
i don't know i i hope so he's an idiot
if he doesn't
and um it was uh colin said it's so
beautiful i said i know
how can you say you're not very
interesting when over the past
year your cocktail videos alone have
just
blown up and become such an adored part
of social media
yeah i'm interesting when i had a drink
in my hand
everyone is at least they think they are
you know
well too accurate i was also reading
that there was a point in this project
when you two were reading for the
opposite roles
so just for fun here have you ever
thought through
what the movie might look like if he had
played tusker and you had played sam
yeah and i can't i can't really picture
it
it sounds funny i think that i think
that we did it the way we were supposed
to do it
um but yeah like you said i mean harry
offered
me the role of sam and
and that was the way we went into it
colin was going to play tuscany and then
i i kept reading it and thinking
something's wrong it doesn't something
feels wonderful
and then colin comes to me one day he
goes we should switch rules
and i said yeah i've been thinking the
same thing so we went to harry and poor
harry
you know it was just you know like oh
god
why did i get stuck with these two
and and then he said all right well
let's read uh let's read it
let's you know let's pick some scenes
and we'll read them one more room the
other way and then we did and it was
pretty evident that that was the way it
was supposed to be
i mean after seeing the movie i can't
see it any other way yeah it's weird you
can't you can't
no i can't see it so i've got a
two-parter for you now
as far as uh working with congos so what
is
one way that your unique approaches to
your work
maybe served the film very well and then
what's a way
that colin maybe challenges you to adapt
that improved your work
yes okay those are great questions um
how come you can't do every interview
ever
um i'm so glad we're recording this i'm
telling you you're
you're great you um i think yes
to your first question um our approaches
are are different i'm much more i
will stray outside the script
i'll improvise quite a bit i'll repeat
things
i'll go back in like that
like the scene in the in the bed where
we fall out of bed a lot of that is
it it's in the script but then i i just
sort of expanded it and changed
and and i'll throw things in to
just you know
just i don't know why i don't have no
idea why um to keep it
i guess to keep it fresh to keep it
honest to keep it real but without
certainly
um destroying harry's beautiful
script um and luckily harry was
fine with that so i'm much more likely
to do things like that
if i can if colin says something to me
we're riding in the car
and he has a line that i have a line
that he has a line
then i have a line if i couldn't hear
him i would just say what
and he'd have to repeat the line and
but it came from the i mean i sort of
heard him but i wanted just to say what
because
it was so loud in there it just seemed
more natural
and i think what that does is it it
keeps you on your toes
it keeps both of us on our toes and i
think that's a good thing
regarding what colin is so is so
wonderful
um and he's very pain he's much more
patient
than i am uh and uh on set
i like to move very quickly and he's
much more relaxed and you know off
off screen i'd be sitting there going
well why aren't we shooting i don't
understand why this is taking so long
this is ridiculous
i mean it's only a one-page scene this
is just silly
you know and i'd sort of go harry what
are we doing and colin would go
stanley just relax it's fine don't worry
about it it's only five o'clock i know
but i wanna
um so he's uh he taught me a good lesson
i'm gonna have to let you go soon sadly
but before i do every single time i do
an interview
i always ask my colleagues if they have
any questions for the person that i'm
lucky enough to talk to
and one of the hottest topics that was
suggested by the collider staff is they
all want to know what it was like for
you working with michael bay
so i know that you've
already described his process is i
believe manic and frantic
so maybe what would you say is a con
but also a pro of working that way
especially on a gigantic blockbuster set
like the transformers movies
the the pro the pro is you
you get a paycheck you get a real
paycheck and that's exciting
that's always exciting um
the pro is also you get to go to lots of
different locations where you probably
never go in your
entire life like chicago i'm kidding
but no you know um but then
also i think the
another this is you know the only the
best way to describe it
is steve buscemi who worked with michael
a couple of times described it
the best way he goes it's like making an
independent film with a lot of money and
that is true
that there is what i really like about
michael
is that he loves actors and and he's
very very spontaneous
um you can walk on to the set
and you might have no idea what you're
going to do that day
and that is for some people that's fine
for some people it freaks them out
i i had a great i actually had a really
great time working with him
um he he's super smart
he um the the only
the hard part is sometimes when it comes
to the stunts
um because there isn't a lot of
preparation
it can be a bit dangerous understandable
yeah given your experience on sets like
that and also what you brought up
a little earlier if you did sign on to
direct
you know a massive budget blockbuster
what is a quality about your previous
sets that you would want to bring to
those
in order to i don't know make it the
most
successfully creative experience
possible spontaneity
being able to uh and preparation
i really like to prepare i'd like to be
as prepared as possible
and then be spontaneous when i need to
be
preparation allows for spontaneity i
i feel the same way that's why i'm
looking at a mile long list of questions
right now so i could play around on the
spot but also i have to let you go i
could i could truly talk about
supernova all day long you are
phenomenal in it and i
can't recommend it enough to everybody
out there the movie is in theaters
now and also you could see it digitally
on february 16th and
please do not miss it stanley thank you
so much for taking the time to chat with
us today
thank you so much it really was a
pleasure